cheers the dirty 30 trailer is out
forgot this was in the shot the reaction
from the crowd was quite intense there's
a release date that's off your chest it
feels so good and it's actually fun
because it's the day after my birthday
and four days before graces so we're
gonna get to like celebrate birthdays
about a birthday movie when it comes out
and I'm turning 30 this year so I am
also involved in this conversation we're
gonna do a rapid-fire round all about it
all right we are ready favorite moment
from the trailer I love when Adam
lustick goes golf my favorite part is
right when it transitions to so pumped
up pop up Jam and Flula goes what you're
doing you're crazy idiot thank you very
good Flula I love when memory punches
the cake stay okay it drew blood
who got the wildest and craziest on
scent we honestly we kind of had this
long-standing thing of being pretty
professional on our sets because we also
shoot within really tight time
constraints and whoo so there's your
boring answer most embarrassing onset
moment I don't want to do a spoiler but
I definitely had to like pop a squat at
some point so yeah I won't say when or
how but that's fun to act best cameo
rhett and Link are in it and their
characters are so so funny
your Monsen is also in the film and he
is incredible he probably gets put in
the most vulnerable position in the
movie for those he's at least dressed
for the longest period of time
Gracie's midriff is out like the whole
movie that turns out I have a belly
button and it's in this movie it's on
credit and one word to describe dirty
thirty rambunctious romp fun without an
are worried well Cheers
to dirty 30 congratulations